[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's paul feinbaum paul feinbaum show on
espn radio and he joins us on the
program was it a good weekend for
college football paul
if uh for all you folks in alabama turn
your radio down for a second it was a
spectacular weekend uh
dan i saw some guy did a
compilation i don't know how he did it
but he said this was one of the eight or
nine most exciting days in the history
of college football and to think about
when that game that you just referenced
ended in in dallas at 3 30 it was one of
the most spectacular comebacks ever for
oklahoma to think that that wouldn't be
the best game in the state of texas that
day uh it is truly remarkable uh
speaking of uh college station uh
october 8th was a day that all aggie
fans
circled and i do this so we do this
traveling sec show like like college
game day and i think when we picked on
sunday it was like the fifth best game
of the weekend in the sec because nobody
nobody thought a m was going to win it
wasn't because you know they don't have
a good program they just got through
losing to arkansas and mississippi state
i mean they were done
yeah i felt the same way and then all of
a sudden i mean we have so many great
stories now in college football but i
wonder if they're real stories is iowa a
top five team in your opinion is
cincinnati a top five team if the season
ended today do you really think the
committee is going to have iowa and
cincinnati in the final four
no i was i was talking to somebody
earlier and they said unequivocally
cincinnati has to be in the college
football playoff i'm going that's great
it it's it's it's columbus day uh and
that does not mean anything because
there are so many other things that
could happen and and i i'm not going to
bore you with the playoff predictor but
all alabama has to do dan is win out and
i know for most schools that sounds like
a big hill to climb it's for alabama
it's not
uh they they win the rest of the regular
season games and b georgia therein that
also means georgia would be in assuming
they don't lose to some ridiculous uh in
a ridiculous upset so then you only have
two spots left so you know cincinnati
better uh better have a bulldozer to
knock that door down if that's going to
be the case what happened to clemson
i think it's been coming for a while uh
they lost uh one of the one of their
coordinators to uh usf a couple years
ago and i think
it affected their
their play calling a little bit uh i
think sometimes these things get stale
uh and you know they lost a collection
of quarterbacks that go by the name of
deshawn watson and trevor lawrence and i
think just to expect the next guy is
going to walk in there and they also
forgot to recruit premier offensive
lineman
and when you're a new quarterback that
does not work very well what happened to
lsu
uh what happened to lsu is that joe
burrow left and so did about six or
seven other first-round
picks and just because you recruit five
stars doesn't mean you develop them i
mean since joe burrow left his last game
uh ed ogeron
is
is eight and eight
and it's about to get worse uh because
they have florida alabama arkansas and
ole miss and a m
and i i don't i'm not even sure they're
going to have a winning season and
and it is as crazy as this may sound dan
not to you
you follow college football in the south
uh two years after a national before the
two-year anniversary of a national
championship uh co-show could be out and
if you ask has that ever happened before
yes
it happened before 2012 gene chiswick
fired who was this quarterback two years
earlier cam newton
yeah we were talking about that earlier
paulie and i were that you know you lose
that quarterback but you lose borrow you
lose your quarterbacks coach as well
with joe burrow and i was told that you
know coach o is going to be out because
unless he would somehow be able to land
arch manning that uh you know the the
sweepstakes are pretty high with alabama
clemson texas might be the the front
runners for arch manning but i don't
know i just can't imagine that uh coach
oh is going to survive even after two
years here
i think arch manning's still in the
eighth grade yeah i'm not sure
but
yeah i i don't think he'll be around
very i mean
they they they love this guy and you you
probably have interviewed him before he
he's hard not to like but i think he's a
very average football coach and and lsu
needs something spectacular uh and they
they do not have that right now
are you all in on the big ten
i'm i'm starting to uh watch a lot more
big ten network it took me a long time
to find it dan but the big ten is the
story of college football i'm sure i'll
get a pink slip today from the sec
network for saying that but hey i'm sure
they're not paying attention right now
and yeah there are so many great stories
and and i think the story that we buried
five weeks ago may come back and be the
big 10 champion and and that's ohio
state they are looking alive again
and and i i think the schedule suits
them quite nicely are you all in on
michigan your good buddy jim harbaugh
i i don't know what you're talking about
yeah if i'm just thinking dan i need
some help here because you you've handed
out nba trophies and nfl trophies and
i've never really had to deal with stuff
like that but if somehow jim harbaugh
wins the national championship i'm i'm
looking for a country to uh to evacuate
to
i i just don't think it's going to be
safe for the two of us to live in the
great united states of america
if you ran usc's football program or usc
athletics what would you do
as your head coach
i would hire james franklin uh i think
he he checks a lot of boxes in in the
sense that he's a very good ceo which
means he'll bring in a top flight staff
and from there i i think
this this program needs to be run like a
like a big time operation and it hasn't
been and i think some of the problem is
they've had inept athletic directors out
there in the past they don't anymore
they hired mike bone from cincinnati and
and and in l.a
dan you you have to be able to schmooze
and and james franklin is very smooth
and i i expect that program to come back
big and i think he would be the best
choice every time i bring this up
because i had a source who told me that
whatever whenever they fired clay hey
james franklin stops on their list and
then the people at penn state are mad at
me because i bring up james franklin i'm
thinking
take it as a compliment like your coach
will be in demand he's either going to
get a new contract at penn state or
he'll get a contract at usc
i can't believe college football fans
get mad at commentators for speaking the
truth that is that's a new one um
yeah i i if if i'm over if i'm over at
penn state right now i'd be lit i'd be
i'd be searching the yellow pages for a
new coach because i think franklin is
leaving
paul always great to talk to you thank
you buddy
dan it was my pleasure thank you that's
paul feinbaum host of the paul feinbaum
show on the mother ship voice of the sec